hey everyone er welcome i'm super
excited to be hosting the first hockey
phase a open source office hours
i'm happy to host it with lissandra a
core maintainer of transformers and lead
of the open source team at hogan phase
and quentin the core maintainer of
datasets so if you have any questions
feel free to ask them in discord or
directly in youtube you can see the link
to join discord at the bottom
and yeah having said that welcome this
andre welcome quentin i don't know if
this android you would like to
introduce yourself and tell us a bit
about transformers
sure thank you thank you omar so i'm
lysander i'm i'm leading the open source
team at hugging face i've been part of
hugging face for uh
close to two and a half years now so
i've been involved in many open source
projects along the way um and i'll be
happy to to give a small update on
first well transformers and uh and more
generally uh
also the course that's coming uh that's
coming soon and then
yeah so first uh maybe to just quickly
mention the course we have the part two
of the hugging phase course coming out
next monday which is going to be a super
super cool because we'll be looking at
many different nlp tasks in the first
part of the course it was just a single
task whereas here we're diving deep
inside question answering a token
classification and
complex tasks like these
with the whole post processing and
pre-processing
in which we dive into so super excited
about that and i'm really looking
forward to
to seeing many community members there
for transformers more specifically
there are a few uh
maybe directions we can have general
road map which i can share that would be
interesting
interesting for the community
maybe the first big aspect is that up to
now uh transformers was mainly nlp
focused
in the recent months it has changed
quite a bit with
the uh speech sprint with wave to vector
and the xmsr
this is going to continue this way
we are going to continue
working on the speech capabilities for
transformers and for the general plug-in
phase i think quantum content you can
speak a bit about that regretting data
sets too
it's also the case concerning vision
we've done some efforts to integrate fit
the vision transformers
bait
better clip
and other models are to come in the
future so that's one big aspect of
transformers that's going to to evolve
quite a bit
the second one is that recently we've
refactored the pipelines a bit to fully
use the gpus
whereas before it was super hard to get
100 gpa utilization
uh we've completely changed that for the
pi torch side of the pipeline so they
should be much more efficient on gpus
now it's quite experimental still but
we're really really looking for feedback
here so if you can use them i would be
happy to hear any comments you have
and finally a super super cool thing
that's upcoming it's not it's not yet
completely released but it will be soon
is the ability to push to the hub inside
repositories
actual code actual model code and
tokenizer code
which can be leveraged then in
transformers so it means that if you're
using for example you have your own bert
model
with a few tweaks with for example a
layer added here a layer normally there
you don't need to open a pull request to
transformers to add it so that others
may benefit from it you can just push it
to a hub to a hugging face hub repo
and alongside your weights and tokenizer
files and so on and it will be used
directly in transformers and other users
will be able to use it too so this
should unlock quite a few uh
big
features
and just sharing capabilities across
models
so i think those are the three big
points for transformers so maybe omar or
carter you can you can take like the
lead
yeah that's quite exciting just a
comment from the community is that
looking forward to the new course i yeah
and we are also quite excited about
launching the second part next week
i don't know quentin if you would like
to go next
yeah sure and i can already see some
questions about about data sets so
that's really interesting so just be uh
before going to the question uh
just to introduce a little bit myself so
i've been working on the
data sets library of hacking phase for
a year and a half now
and so in the beginning it was only uh
it was mainly focused on nlp but now we
are working a lot on
adding
more audio data set and more vision data
that's exactly what we are working on
right now
and one
nice thing that i also wanted to to show
you is the uh
the new preview the data set preview
feature that we added on the hub so here
if you can see my screen
it's the list of like all the data sets
that you have on the hub and just very
quickly
you can see that if we access the glue
data set you can see on the top that
there is a preview
of the data set so that you can explore
each data set this way
and what's also really nice is that it
also works with your own data sets so
here for for example
uh is a page of one of my own data sets
i just uploaded the csvs on the on the
hub and here i got the preview
in real time so as soon as i uploaded my
csv i was already able to to preview
the data set so that's a really really
big feature that we just added and uh i
would love to have some feedbacks from
you guys uh on this
then uh two other things that i also
wanted to show was first
the new uh bigger
turn software feature that we added to
data set which is the
2tf data set which is now like the main
entry point to
use the data set loaded with the hugging
phase datasets library
to use with tensorflow in your training
and you can feed it directly to the
model.fit method like but
in keras for example
and finally the
final change i just wanted to mention is
that we we have now like really nice
features or audio data sets
here
so here for example you can in the
documentation explain how to load the
common voice data set which is a pretty
well known audio data set
and in it
you can get access to all the audio data
directly and
it does all the decoding of the mp3 into
the arrays
on the fly so don't you don't have to
to do that uh
yourself
but so that's pretty much all i wanted
to uh
to say so i can stop sharing my screen
now
all right so that's uh that's a lot
that's pretty much it
awesome thanks a lot
uh yeah so now we'll spend some time
answering questions from the community
feel free to make them directly in
discord or make them in youtube
yeah so let me begin
with
this question some from brown bandrai
are there any plans about new products
in the pipeline and what is the role of
open source in those pro in those
products because we love open source and
we love it as well
i don't know if lissandra
would like to answer that one yeah i can
say that
um so i don't think there's any plans
that uh about new commercial products
that we can really share but there's the
uh we're really going to push forward
with the uh
platform aspect of the of the hub so to
have this central place where people
where users and community members can
just share their models not
necessarily across transformers but
across all
possible
machine learning frameworks so may that
be a
spacey team lnai and then
or transformers um
and so since this uh since this is
definitely going to be integrated with
uh
all the uh
like communities and open source
software that would like to be
integrated with um then we're really
going to push that forward and of course
the open source will be a core aspect of
that platform that we're working on
um
so i guess something that
we're looking forward in the future is
just yeah making open source even more
accessible uh
by simple platforms very simple
uh usage and apis
um across open source
awesome thanks
er yeah then next question is
how can i start learning about
transformers and contributing to the hog
and face ecosystem
okay so
i think those are two different
questions the first one is how can i
start learning about transformers well i
guess here the the best place to start
is is with the huggy face course
part one was released a few months ago
and part two is released next monday
so i would definitely recommend this as
the most useful for learning about
transformers since uh it doesn't teach
about transformers only but about the
whole hugging face ecosystem with data
sets with tokenizers with the hub
so you get a full spectrum of everything
that's going on and regarding
contributing to the hugging face echo
system um i guess here the easiest thing
to do is just to go inside the libraries
look at the issues look at the pr's we
have some good first issues tags for
issues where we think that people that
are not yet introduced to our libraries
can still contribute
that's definitely the best place to
start contributing in my opinion maybe
content you have something to add
regarding contributing
that's uh that's pretty much it and yeah
don't simply don't hesitate to uh open
issues and to discuss on github uh we uh
like we have a full team working on
helping everyone
getting started and uh if they have
questions so yeah don't hesitate
cool thanks
uh
the next question is from why this yeah
he's asking or he's saying that i am
curious if it would be interesting to
have comments uh sections in spaces
demos
i think it will generate more
interactions and energy yeah so this is
something that we are discussing
internally uh thanks for the
product feedback
and yeah thanks a lot
okay
uh
i think you already answered a bit of
this uh when you presented this android
but maybe
the two of you would like and also
you're pointing with the audio a feature
in datasets but maybe you would like to
expand a bit more about the plans for
the future
right so um
in terms of open source libraries yeah
we're definitely opening up to new
domains we started with nlp but now
we're reaching to audio speech which is
quite mature now but also computer
vision
in transformers we're on we're currently
integrating the receiver model which
will be the first module that can also
support video
video tasks
we're not limited to any of those fields
we're really looking forward to being as
helpful to as many community members as
possible
and regarding the hub i think this is
also the case where we will continue to
try and integrate with as many different
open source libraries that could benefit
from having a hub integration
in quarter maybe you want to add
something about data sets
well yeah but on the dataset side the
thing is uh keep adding more android
more data sets especially for audio and
vision because
for many many of them it's still really
complicated to download them and
just use them in a
limited uh resource
machine i mean so
in datasets we are we plan to add more
and more of them and we have all the
best optimizations to load the audio and
image data
awesome thanks a lot
i think grenting is the most prepared
person to answer this question so the
question is
are there best practices for dynamic
data sets for example a data set with a
weekly snapshot
how is an update best automated
yeah thanks for the question christopher
so it's really it's really interesting
to have dynamic data sets you can think
of wikipedia for example like each like
every month they release a new dump and
you can download
the latest updates
from wikipedia
and usually usually the best practices i
would say would be to uh
if you want to have a dynamic data set
would be to have a standard way for each
release like to access the data
so for example
if your data are hosted on the hugging
face hub you can
have like each
version in a different
directory for example of your data set
and then
in the code
you won't have to
to modify anything regarding the way you
load the data set except that you can
just pass an additional parameter saying
uh which version you want to load them
and so as soon as the new versions have
the same formats or stored in the same
structure as your the old version it's
uh something that
that you can do
awesome i hope that answers the question
yeah and if you have any follow-up
question feel free to ask directly in
youtube or in discord
okay the next question is a jax
tensorflow and by torch are all
supported in transformers which should i
use
which is holding phase strategy moving
forward with having multiple
laboratories
that's a that's a good question
i think here um
jack's tensorflow and pytorch are all
very different frameworks with um even
if they solve some of the same problems
they're each targeted at some specific
problems like for example tensorflow
being way older has an ecosystem which
is way more mature for example with uh
relation to serving and to efficiency in
production
pytorch is still
progressing quite a bit here with a
torch serve and jax is super efficient
on cpus but you're basically going to
use the libraries for different use
cases
and so i think here we're really going
to focus on
the aspects that make each library shine
for example with pytorch it's super
malleable it's super flexible with what
you want to do with it so we're going to
continue implementing very researchy
type of models in pytorch as it makes
little sense here
and it's definitely designed for that
and for tensorflow we're going to
continue optimizing for uh
while simple usage simple
uh integration with keras and just all
around uh
high performance and production great
setups and for jax uh here it's a bit
different it's it's optimized for
parallelization so we're going to
continue with that moving forward
especially focusing on maybe bigger
models
which fit on big tpus
basically just
trying to focus on what makes each
library shine and adapting transformers
to that so if you're looking for a
general approach i'd recommend pytorch
to start off because we have uh because
departure side of transformers is the
most mature uh but if you're looking
into like very high parallelization very
high performance i would still
recommend jax and if you're looking to
look for something uh very careless uh
dramatic i would of course recommend
tensorflow
thanks there's like a direct follow-up
question is the ucf tutor for yx xla is
also available
in by torch
uh yeah of course we see a future for
jax otherwise we wouldn't have
converted a lot of models
into jacks
um there's definitely a future for jax
uh
maybe not as big as uh
as tensorflow pytorch uh because right
now it's more it's more niche but we
really trust that it's going to
uh continue working on itself and
improve as time goes on of course
there's a xla available in high torch
and tensorflow as well
um
but
jax's approach
is still a bit different and you can do
things in jacks way simpler than you can
do them in python or intensify
okay thanks a lot we have two very
related questions so let me show you the
two questions first and then we can
answer them
so from andrew mean in discord they are
asking if that hogan faces currently
looking for machine learning engineers
and what are the top qualities that we
are looking for mle
and
another question from discord as well
from brandel 1507 is what should i be
working on if my aim is to land a job at
hogging phase uh
so yeah maybe a quentin or lysandre and
if you would like to share a bit more
about
what that ml engineer does at hoginface
go ahead uh if you want to start
okay sure um
so i think working working at hugging
face requires a bit of a different
mindset to to traditional machine
learning engineers because what we're
working on at hugging face isn't uh
actual models like we're not training
models and we're not looking for the
best uh
accuracy here at the best performing
model we're actually building tools to
do that so it requires uh to to think of
it differently than just working on the
application and it requires uh
understanding what you would be really
looking for when working at hugging face
is it
to make software that's accessible to as
most people as possible is it to
make software that really revolutionizes
the field
rather than
optimizing a model and working on
data centric aspects of the job i think
uh
usually
yeah the job of ml engineers at hogging
face is why it requires the same skills
as other machine learning engineers
it's still a bit different and
and it requires a different drive i
think what do you think
yeah i totally agree
one thing that i would also add is that
in addition to
all the
standard the machine learning engineer
skills that you might expect
you also need to have like to be very
close to the community and to everything
that is going on in the in the fields
like nlp vision or audio
uh to be able to uh to know what are
going
to be the the best tools and what are
going the best ways to develop and
democratize the access to all these
models and data sets
um
so yeah if you are really close to the
community to what everyone is either be
doing and also to the research what are
the
the highest like the biggest trend uh
recently it's really a big plus
and and to add to that i think that the
second question was about courses and uh
and just machine learning courses and if
that would help uh personally in my uh i
took a computer science degree in a
master a few years ago which didn't have
a focus on artificial intelligence or
machine learning
i i got all my expertise in the
coursera's courses
which are still
not beginner
level but a bit
so
and still like because i was really
really motivated by the field i learned
a lot on my own i worked a lot on my
projects and uh having a strong software
engineering core with a huge drive and
interest for machine learning
can definitely lend you a job if if our
values are aligned
awesome yeah i fully agree with everyone
everything that both of you said
yeah going to the next question i think
lysandre pretty much answered this
before so the question is is the focus
of hacking fees only on nlp frameworks
and the answer is no
we are
building collaborations with other
libraries
in other domains and also transformers
is starting to be applied since few
months ago maybe more than a few months
since
er
early summer in computer vision and
audio
we don't have a much work in 3g
transformer
right now but that's also like an area
of interest to us
and
there's also the very recent widget that
was introduced uh maybe last week
about image segmentation which is really
really cool
they are amazing that you must check
that out it's insane
yeah we i'll share the link in in the
comments in few seconds
all right uh so
this is a question from geeker decodes
the question is
i want them to understand if there is
batch processing supported across
attention heads in multi-head attention
of
a bird engaged by torch model
i guess the question here is to is to
understand if we do a batch uh batch
processing of sequences inside bird and
uh and yes we do we don't uh
um
like you can match up to as many
sequences you want
in parallel it just depends on the
amount of memory that you have and it's
not only for a bird
encased pt model it's all models and
transformers
all checkpoints
that's that's one of the core principles
of
each of our models
awesome thanks
we have a question from emmanuel hoover
new architectures are going to be
implemented in transformers
or separate repositories as mentioned
that's that's an excellent question
um
so up to now uh we've been mostly
implementing well we've been only
implementing new architectures inside
transformers
via pull request but as i was mentioning
in the updates we're going to offer the
ability to push your own code to a hub
repository and then use that as the uh
as the central uh definition of the
model um well this uh well we're going
to push for this we will still uh really
motivate people to share their models
inside transformers uh
as much as possible
offering this is basically to remove the
constraint to have to open a pull
request you have to go through the
entire review and merging process uh if
you want to get something out quick if
you want to how to to share your model
and
and basically share it with your friends
and just show how it's working but if
you have
like a research project or something
that
could be really helpful for the entire
field then we definitely recommend
opening a pr to transformers sharing
your model with others this way we can
have a thorough testing of that model we
can
test it our ci documented share it with
our community members it's just the best
way to have more visibility on your
models
awesome thanks a lot the next question
is uh is there a forum it is like to
discuss with hogging face members and
ask doubts on how to get started on an
issue i want to work on
i think i can answer that one so first
the link to the discord is below and
there is also a forum but normally our
philosophy is to discuss directly on the
issues in the github repositories
that helps having all of the discussion
there and it's like more dynamic we can
discuss directly over the code
so yeah i think that's the best medium
to discuss but maybe quentin or lysandre
have like other suggestions
i think you covered it well one more
awesome okay uh so we only have like uh
three more minutes uh
so let me put the last few questions
uh
sorry yeah so a kicker decodes ask do
you plan to support models with pytorch
transformer attention encoder decoder
module types instead of custom modules
that's supported as of today
so that's a very interesting question
too
which which
is very linked to the philosophy that we
have in transformers the philosophy
being first we want the models to be
extremely readable like we want people
to be able to go and set the code
inspect the code
and just understand what's happening
inside the model and the second one is
that we want the whole processing uh to
be done inside a single file so we don't
want uh so for example we're never going
to have let's say a attention layer
that's going to be shared among all our
all our different models because when
inspecting it would mean
going from the basic model
implementation to the abstract
implementation and just having a back
and forth between the two
files which would make understanding
quite painful
but regarding the question to exactly
support python transformer attention or
basically
the standard modules offered by pytorch
um we're definitely not closed to having
support for those uh basically if
if someone contributes a model
leveraging those uh modules uh we'd be
very happy to welcome those to the
library
for our existing models we're not going
to refactor them to simplify them simply
because that would be a super big change
that would probably hinder comprehension
of the models by our users
which isn't something that we want and
it would result in
modules that are way less flexible than
what we currently have for with our own
custom implementations so the answer is
in the future if there's some
new uh models that are offered with
those no problem at all but we're not
going to reflect with the old motors
let's hear about the news
no worries
uh yeah so let's answer like three
last questions so this one is a quick
one are we going to discuss prs from the
red point office hours now the idea is
to discuss more about the strategy new
updates and high level questions and not
the super specific things
for discussions we usually discuss
directly in the prs
a few people were asking about julia
so
the question is to use julia or plan to
use julia would you like to give us high
level view of the stack
um i think omar you have the most
experience with uh with the julia
related uh
hub integrations though
yeah uh sure so right now there's like
this uh
so right now we have a library called
hacking facehub it's like a very nice
python client that allows people to
programmatically upload models to the
hub download models from the hub it
doesn't necessarily need to be
transformer based models so we have
mixins for keras for example
this is being used by other 15 libraries
this is used
with spacey for example to push models
to the hub
and right now there's like this nice
integration with julia that allows
people
to download models uh
using this python client to run the
python code in julia and to download the
files
directly from github so there's already
like an option to
upload and download models from github
using julia and use a
version control and all of the other
benefits that github offers you
with julia but for transformers library
there are like no plans to have
something like that with julia
okay i think we can
answer
let me see
yeah i think we can answer like this
last question and finish for today this
is mostly for quentin i would say what
is the upcoming plan on data set to
fine-tune the models
and the chart
yeah i understand the question
yeah actually i'm also not sure i
understand it uh
hey i wish
feel free to follow up in the discord uh
let me put the discord here we didn't
get to answer all of the questions so
feel free to keep asking them in the
office hours
channel in the discord server
and afterwards we can answer any
follow-up questions or clarifications
yeah anyways thanks everyone for joining
thank you alyssa andre and thank you
quentin for joining us today
thanks everyone for being here
thank you everyone for being here thank
you more for organizing
yeah thanks a lot see you all